this is the airlander 10 from hybrid air
vehicles it's a design for a huge new
type of zero emissions aircraft that
would slowly carry up to 100 passengers
through the skies in a more scenic way
of traveling short distances of around
450 miles now i know what you're
thinking this looks like an airship and
other than the goodyear blimp there's
only really one other famous airship
inexplicable appalling tragedy is a
matter of seconds but we've come a long
way in the past century so our blimps
about to make a comeback well maybe one
day but right now it's not quite there
yet
so as always we're going to look at
where hybrid air vehicles is right now
where the company wants to be and then
examine what it needs to do to get there
but let's start with where they want to
be
the privately funded company is
developing two aircraft the airlander 10
which is set to come out first and then
the larger airlander 50. airlander 10
would be capable of spending five days
in the air and will be powered by
hydrogen fuel cells to eliminate
emissions depending on the configuration
of the aircraft the maximum range would
be around four thousand nautical miles
that's slightly further than the
distance from miami to london but the
company told me that airlander would
mainly be used as an eco-friendly way to
travel between cities for example the
company says that airlander 10 could
carry 100 passengers from seattle to
vancouver in four and a quarter hours as
opposed to the roughly three hours it
takes for the total journey time by
plane and to explain what the company
means by total journey time here's ceo
tom grundy think about that journey on a
regional jet the time you spend in the
air is pretty limited it's the time
getting to the airport it's getting
through security it's getting to the
gate these dominate your journey time so
with airlander we're opening up
point-to-point services away from the
airport closer to the city center where
that getting on board is a lot easier
and quicker the company has its sights
set on delivering its aircraft from 2026
onwards and has signed a deal with
spanish airline air nostrum for 10
aircraft to be delivered in the same
year
so if that's where hybrid air vehicles
want to be where are they right now
well the company has developed a
prototype aircraft which it's used to
conduct a string of test flights that
have helped inform the future design of
the aircraft it was during one of those
test flights that the aircraft had an
unexpected impact with the ground the
reason that you're taking the risk is to
expand the envelope of the airplane and
learn what it can do ask tom what the
difference was between airlander and a
conventional airship and he told me that
while the hindenburg was filled with
flammable hydrogen airlander would be
filled with helium which is inert
airlander is also designed to drift back
down to the ground whenever the engines
stop so it won't suddenly float away we
only use enough of that helium just to
not quite lift the empty weight of the
airplane the whole shape of the airplane
is shaped like a big wig the company has
for now concluded its flight testing and
is focused on getting type certification
later this year it's also looking to
build out its production headquarters in
the north of england so if they've flown
a test vehicle signed a deal with an
airline and they're on the way to
certification why is this technology not
quite there yet well let's start with
that zero emission flying ambition
see while hybrid air vehicles have
ambitions to power their aircraft using
hydrogen fuel cells for now they're
still using regular fuel to power the
engines though tom did tell me that
their aerodynamic design and buoyancy
still resulted in 75 percent less co2
emissions compared to an aircraft even
when using kerosene there's also a
question mark around where these
vehicles will take off and land as if
they're operating outside of airports
new terminals will need to be built and
then there's perception after all 36
people died in hindenburg disaster and
that's why it remains one of the most
famous airships yes i think everybody
looks to anchor their view of what our
product is on on something that they
know we're surprised you know people
often told us about the 1930s
so for hybrid air vehicles zero emission
airlander to become a reality the
company is going to have to get their
aircraft certified build out their
production capacity develop those new
hydrogen fuel cell engines build out
take off and landing terminals and then
convince everyone that their aircraft is
safe if they can do that then maybe
we'll be seeing far more blimps in our
sky
[Music]